what's up everybody welcome back to my
youtube channel richard on data if
you're new here my name is richard and
this is the channel where we talk about
all things data data science statistics
and programming subscribe for all kinds
of content just like this and hit the
notification Bell so YouTube notifies
you whenever I upload a video so there's
this question which comes up a lot which
is can data science predict the stock
market I mean who doesn't want to work
some magic in Python develop a
classifier and then immediately know
whether they should buy or sell their
stocks then you could become a wolf of
Wall Street and make thousands or
millions of dollars then you've got the
data people who aren't really in it for
the money or so they say
but they just want to play around a
little bit and build some algorithms to
solve notoriously complex problems as
many of you know in the last month the
stock market has fallen off a cliff and
let's be real if you had an algorithm
that would have told you a month ago
that we were right at the peak and it
was time to sell or that were as low as
it's gonna get right now and that it's
actually the perfect time to buy that
would be awesome it's also a little
known fact that over 70% of all stock
trades that happen in the US are done by
BOTS and algorithms also Wall Street
hires tons of data scientists and one of
their main goals is to tackle this very
problem but at the same time it's
famously known that a monkey randomly
throwing darts at a bunch of stocks has
just about as much chance of beating the
S&P 500 as a lot of hedge fund and
mutual fund companies do so before we
dig into this let's define what question
we're even talking about here because
usually when people talk about the
market they're referring to the entire
stock market and that's tracked by
things like the Dow Jones Industrial
Average which is an index representing
the performance of 30 different
companies or the S&P 500 which tracks
the performance of 500 different
companies however when most people
partake in this exercise in the data
science context they're talking about
stocks at the individual level so what
everyone wants to do in order to be a
millionaire is to figure out which
stocks are going to go up a thousand
percent over the next year or they want
to tie
particular stalks so they sell at the
right time and they know exactly when to
buy so we really have two different
questions here over a longer horizon
let's say a year or more can we predict
a stock's performance and then four day
traders can we predict how the stock is
gonna close on the next day and then
whether we should buy or sell we're
gonna look at the tools people use to
tackle this problem how they've done at
it and then the shortcomings so most
investors make their decisions based on
things like revenue expenses profits
basic things that come from financial
statements and SEC filings however a
data scientist can set this problem up
by leveraging what's known as
alternative data and these are things
like a company's social media activity
product reviews credit card purchases
basic things like that which are fairly
publicly available one idea that's even
been pitched is the number of cars in
the company's parking lot talk about
your data being everywhere so that all
sounds great but what's the problem well
actually one of the biggest problems is
a lack of data so for metrics like
quarterly earnings you literally only
get those once per quarter so even if a
company's been around for a hundred
years
you only have 400 data points to work
with credit card transactions are
typically reported at a weekly level and
that's a lot better than at a quarterly
level but let's just say a company's
only been public for five years you
still only have 52 weeks in a year times
five years equals 260 weeks worth of
data points one approach that some
researchers have taken if they want
daily sales is this
they'll take weekly sales divided by
seven to get the mean and then add some
statistical noise just to capture some
of the natural variation that happens
with sales so let's just say tomorrow
sales they equal today's sales times
some random noise factor like 0.97 or
1.02
or something like that one recent MIT
study took this approach they utilized
alternative data and they found they
could predict quarterly earnings better
than Wall Street 57% of the time that's
prime
sure but probably not the most exciting
performance you've ever heard of before
there's tons more information out there
which people are collectively trying to
leverage people talk about using Google
search volume which there's definitely
some evidence of success with that in
particular people are trying to combine
machine learning algorithms with text
mining so using textual content out
there on the Internet in fact some
people have even tried to use Twitter
messages as a predictor for stock
performance and from a methodology
standpoint the deep learning technique
of artificial neural networks is getting
a lot of positive press right now just
for being a really appropriate and
well-suited approach to the stock market
prediction problem now let's look at
another example of somebody trying to
tackle this problem this is credit to
the data scientist Gerais you his full
work will be in the description and now
there are other examples out there of
people trying to do this but I think his
performance is pretty typical if not
better than how most people do basically
he uses some Python modules he does some
work to tune the hyper parameters and he
sets out to predict the price of Google
stock he uses the years 2014 through
2016 as training data and then 2017 and
then a little bit after as testing data
now he plays around with a lot of
methods K nearest neighbors one example
but he also gets into some deep learning
methods so he tries multi-layer
perceptron and then he also uses the
Python module called stalker which makes
use of artificial neural networks this
is clearly a very skilled data scientist
with a lot of domain knowledge about the
financial industry and he's making use
of state-of-the-art technology so let's
see how he did so looking at the whole
picture here the model actually gets its
estimate for the price of Google stock
one year after the fact pretty close but
the confidence interval for that
estimate goes all the way from 200 to
1,800 so as a longer-term investor this
would not exactly be anything to inspire
a lot of decisions for me it does do a
little bit better in the short term but
you do see it's unable to accurately
pick up a couple big
and big declines that Google stock makes
in particular there's a huge drop in
early 2018 that there's no way this
model can predict a full year out and
now for the day traders notice that the
model gets it right fifty nine percent
of the time that the price of the stock
will go up but it's actually wrong more
often than it's right only correctly
predicting that the stock will go down
forty nine percent of the time to
provide a little context there was a
period in February of 2018 where
Google's stock dropped by about 20
percent over a very short period of time
and this was due to a multitude of
factors both on the local level and on
the more global level so on the local
level Google had failed to meet earnings
expectations over that period of time
but on a more global level investors
across the entire stock market were
beginning to worry about increased
inflation which would lead the Federal
Reserve to probably increase interest
rates and because of this growing fear
there was just a massive sell-off
across the entire board it was really
the perfect storm for Google to have a
large price drop this was in February of
2018 try predicting that as this model
tries to do in March of 2017
so through the couple examples that
you've seen you see that it's not like
there's no predictive performance
whatsoever
but a lot of these attempts to predict
the stock market do seem to fall a
little bit flat yet there are advanced
powerful algorithms being thrown at this
problem there are tons of really bright
data scientists with lots of domain
knowledge about the individual companies
about the financial industry as a whole
and they don't necessarily have a lot of
time points of data to work with but
there are tons of different features
that they are able to leverage but still
the conventional wisdom is with all of
that the best strategy is still just to
invest in the whole market or in mutual
funds and then just buy and hold so why
is that well there's a few reasons for
that reason number one is what's known
as the efficient market hypothesis this
was a theory proposed by The Economist
Burton Malkiel
and he basically stated that all of the
known information
about a particular stock's price is
already reflected in its current price
and then any change in the stock price
would just reflect the release of new
information or random noise as a result
he contended that stock prices are best
described by a random walk
that is each stock price deviation from
day to day is random and unpredictable
in other words this exercise is largely
pointless there's certainly some grain
of truth to the idea that information
about a stock is deeply embedded into
its current price so he might be onto
something with this reason number two is
you usually cannot predict future shocks
so let's just as an example look back at
the last few years and look at some of
the biggest events which have rattled
the stock market
you've got the outcome of the 2016
election geopolitical tensions with
North Korea and Iran negotiation of a
trade deal with China and the virus
which is currently sweeping over
virtually the entire globe right now all
of these things had dramatic impacts on
the stock market and in order to have
even a remotely accurate prediction over
your relevant time window you would have
had to correctly predict these things if
we take the outcome of the 2016 election
for example most people predicted that
one wrong even the day of let alone
months earlier investors were
understandably very nervous about North
Korea tensions in 2017 China tensions in
2019 Iran tensions in mid 2019 and early
2020 so there were a lot of ups when
things looked good and downs when things
looked bad and ultimately this is all
reliant on things that are done and said
by human beings
specifically by world leaders and just
in the real world you are not gonna
predict things like that with any degree
of great accuracy these are just
examples from the last few years to
illustrate a broader point and that
point is just that when you have a ton
of unknowns which all involve human
beings and human sentiment and you're
combining the uncertainty from a ton of
different things the ability to predict
with any great accuracy is just
infeasible and reason number three is
actually solving this problem creates a
massive conflict of interest there's
probably tons of groups out there that
are solving this problem better than
others probably to the degree that their
algorithm is generating them tons and
tons of money there's absolutely no
reason then for them to treat this as a
research problem and just publish their
methodology so that other people could
get good at this but then let's just
suppose if everyone could actually
accurately predict the stock market they
would do that then eventually over time
the market movement would become the
prediction itself and then nobody would
make any money at all so that doesn't do
anybody any good now my take here is not
to be dismissive of AI and of data
science in general on its role in stock
market prediction not at all there are
algorithms out there that have utilized
unstructured data and they've come up
with stock portfolios that greatly
outperformed the S&P 500 but there's a
real question about how accurate things
can get and how accurate things need to
be and it's really humbling for students
of data science to realize that certain
things cannot be perfect especially when
they revolve around human beings and
human sentiment human beings are
incredibly intricate and complex things
and they have thought processes which
are very nuanced they can be rational
but they're often irrational - and just
frankly the ability to predict their
behaviors and their thoughts has limits
which anyone in the data and artificial
intelligence world do need to grapple
with what do you guys think
why is the stock market prediction
problem so hard to solve let me know
what you think in the comments if you
enjoyed this video and you'd like to
support my work the best thing that you
could do for me is to share this video
so thanks everyone for watching and I'll
see you next time until then Richard on
data